blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to
blinkist.com pakman i want to start
today with one of these
totally dystopian horror stories that's
framed in our modern cultural and
economic system as
entertainment or something nice when in
reality it is a story that shows us just
how bad things are and i'm talking about
this viral story
of a cash scramble five thousand one
dollar bills laid out on an ice rink
in south dakota
where uh during a hockey game during the
sioux falls stampede hockey game on
saturday night
teachers from nearby schools were
invited to grab as many dollar bills as
possible in less than five minutes and
the idea the point of this
was
it's five thousand dollars that the
teachers can secure
to get supplies for their classrooms and
the money was of course donated not for
nothing it was a sponsorship cu mortgage
direct
donated the 5 000 in dollar bills in
exchange for
sponsorship placement on the event
because they're so great and it's an
amazing thing that they're doing so they
get publicity out of it and the idea is
let the teachers go at it picking up
cash and not only is it listen
of course it's demeaning to some degree
to send people out to pick up dollar
bills because it shows a certain degree
of
uh you know financial need that is often
stigmatized in
many cultures not just unique to the
united states the idea of you're
scrambling for dollar bills and stuffing
them in your pants and in your you know
wherever wherever it is that you're
stuffing them
there's you know the idea is it's sort
of oh wow wow crap we're more refined
we're not so crass that we get on our
hands and knees for dollar bills so in
some sense there's that aspect to it but
then it's
teachers but teachers for money for
supplies for their classrooms and it's
another one of these stories where
if things were functioning correctly
this wouldn't be necessary you know that
the classic example breaking bad
tremendous television program
with brian cranston as walter white
as a high school science teacher
chemistry teacher who gets a diagnosis
of lung cancer
um and starts cooking meth
to not only pay for his treatment but to
leave some money for his family so it's
a signal of yes as a teacher he's
underpaid right because he needs to do
this in order to pay for the treatment
and leave some money to his family but
also in a country
that has
single-payer healthcare
universal healthcare of some kind
you don't need to go to cooking and
selling meth in order to pay for your
medical treatment so in many countries
breaking bad just never happens
these are similar stories to the ones
we've done where
little jimmy or little [ __ ] seven
years old is raising money for susie's
cancer treatment and he's making
brownies and blondies and they're
selling them at 75 cents each at school
to fundraise for susie's cancer
treatment how lovely
what an amazing
show of
love and empathy and it is those things
but it is dystopian that it is even
necessary
why are seven-year-olds doing bake sales
to raise money for someone else's cancer
treatment or
machine this is another one i think this
might have been like a prosthetic
but the gist of the story was you know
local machine shop welds a wheelchair
for some kid
who can't afford the wheelchair and his
parents can't afford it well we had a
differently organized medical system you
just get the wheelchair because it's
covered by social insurance or whatever
other system is put in place
and that is very similar to this entire
south dakota thing so like is it
demeaning to be crawling around on your
hands and knees for dollar bills sure
um if it were teachers crawling around
on hands and knees
for themselves for dollar bills then we
would say maybe the teachers aren't paid
enough okay but this was teachers
crawling around on hands and knees to
get a share of five grand
to get supplies
for their classrooms and so maybe we're
not properly funding education at least
in south dakota there are states where
education is relatively well funded
south dakota not a state known for
particularly good infrastructure
healthcare or educational funding so at
the end of the day
we don't seek to
take away
from the humanity
of the people doing the thing right when
little jimmy
says
i want susie to get the cancer treatment
so i'm going to do the bake sale jimmy's
doing a great thing that should be
praised
when the local machine shop says kid
can't afford a wheelchair we're going to
weld one for that those are great acts
when teachers
want their students to have what they
need in the classroom so they say i'll
get on my hands and knees for dollar
bills and stick them in my bra and my
jock strap or whatever it is
they're doing a good thing they're doing
good thing but it is the system that has
failed if teachers
after you know four years of college
many of them two more years for a
master's degree maybe three
you end up on an ice rink wrestling for
dollar bills to pay for pencils we have
systems that have failed here and it's
horrifying and it's okay for us to say
that it's horrifying even if the
teachers are doing a great thing and you
know what it's not even like the
mortgage company is a bad guy they put
up the five grand sure i mean they did
it in exchange for sponsorship it's
still five grand it's a systemic problem
that continues to rear its head in these
dystopian circumstances
remember that whole story
about
her emails
her being hillary clinton's emails i'm
sure you can remember
hillary the story went in 2016
was so irresponsible by her use of a
private email server that she should not
be president and instead it should be
donald trump in fact they would chant
lock her up over her emails michael
flynn led a chant endless chance lock
her up lock her up lock her up
but instead
it is actually donald trump
whose administration was riddled with
private eve private email servers
encrypted messaging apps pers uh private
email accounts
messaging apps and the like
the whole story
of trump will be responsible with
information trump will be responsible
with emails trump will do it all the
right way
have records for everything presidential
records act it was bs
and we know that ivanka and jared were
using personal email for business
related to their roles as advisers to
donald trump but now there's an even
bigger
bombshell revelation on this exact issue
we have now learned that donald trump's
last and final chief of staff he had a
few his last and final chief of staff
was mark meadows mark meadows used here
we go
his own personal cell phone for white
house business
one personal gmail account
a second personal gmail account and the
encrypted messaging app signal
all
for official
white house business
these people are pathetic
and they're liars
but they win by doing this stuff and
i'll get to that in a moment this is all
coming out now along with the powerpoint
planning the trump coup which we talked
about yesterday thanks to a 51-page
report from the house select committee
investigating the january 6 riots in
looking at whether to hold mark meadows
in contempt the house put out a report
detailing his different actions and this
includes the revelation that meadows was
using signal
the app
his personal mobile phone and two
personal gmail accounts for white house
business uh government officials are
supposed to use government-issued
accounts and services to communicate
about their work they're supposed to
forward private messages to government
accounts to have transparency and
accountability and to create a record
trump bragged about he would have the
most transparent administration in
history and meadows didn't do it meadows
is not the only one remember that this
was the reason trump said don't vote for
hillary in 2016. but melania trump used
private email
uh
ivanka trump did it it's a very very
long list of people and yet nobody's
chanting lock him up
lock her up about the trump family and
staff who did this exact same thing
i haven't heard trumpists demanding mark
meadows be imprisoned
as a result of this
they are nowhere because they don't
actually care about this when a
republican does it and this is one of
the reasons they win that's the
important thing the hypocrisy is not new
i doubt many of you are shocked to hear
that mark meadows was doing this and of
course they are hypocrites we knew that
that's not surprising
but another reason they win
is that they do this stuff
brazenly
they bend the rules on voting
they bend the rules on everything they
can they'll write new rules they'll
throw rules out they'll get rules
canceled they'll attack their opponents
on any basis they can
and when it comes to them
they ignore it all they ignore their
values they don't apologize they don't
even justify it to their voters and
that's why they win they don't even go
into the position of justifying it to
their voters they just ignore it
everything and is ignored and they just
power through and they don't care about
being exposed as hypocrites democrats on
the other hand and i get it because
i don't want to be called a hypocrite i
don't want to be a hypocrite
democrats
actually try to avoid being hypocrites
and when they are
they address it even if it's to say it's
defensible for whatever reason
republicans don't do that so democrats
ultimately find themselves in positions
where the only way to proceed is
look like hypocrites and cop to it or
play just as dirty as republicans in
some way shape or form understand that
republicans wanted to jail hillary for
this
and tons of people were doing the exact
same thing in donald trump staff and
they don't even pretend to apologize for
it or write it off as different they
just plow through and it's part of why
they continue to win
uh how democrats deal with that i don't
know because as i've said before
redistricting to pick something
for a while
redistricting is going to be done in a
partisan way
republicans will use it to their
advantage when they have an opportunity
to gerrymander democrats have to do the
same we have to change the system but
democrats have to do the same while
that's the system
this other type of stuff demanding
people be extra judiciously locked up
when they haven't even been accused of a
crime because of the revelation that
they use private email or whatever
i get it we don't want to stoop to their
level their level is disgusting so what
do you do to win i don't know the answer
i don't know the answer but this is a
perfect perfect example of how
republicans are throwing very heavy
stones from weak glass houses
and yet nobody throws any stones back i
don't know what the answer is but i'm
curious to hear from you
we are almost at the end of the year
it's it's shocking actually that 2021 is
already almost over
we want to start off 2022
the it's an election year and the
election is going to start
i think quite early
we want to start off with a bang of
sorts as i've told you we've seen a
decline in membership over the last four
months of the year a lot of people
struggling financially etc
on january 1st we are going to do a
midterm 2022
kick off the year
with a bang membership blowout
like nothing that has ever happened
before you know how trump says it should
never be allowed to happen again well
our accountant and lawyer are telling me
already
whatever you're doing on january 1st
don't do it again because it's going to
be crazy but we are going to do a wild
membership discount on january 1st want
to start off strong i would love for you
to get a membership on january 1st you
want to be notified of how to take
advantage of the
insane immoral discount we're going to
be offering just get on my mailing list
at joinpakman.com
and on january 1st you'll get an email
from me telling you exactly what to do
to take advantage of this it's it's
crazy hopefully the irs has no rules
against outrageous membership discounts
because if they did we'd be screwed we'd
be heading to audit central let me put
it that way or arden as trump likes to
call them
get on my newsletter davidpakman.com and
you'll be notified january 1st
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 percent off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
remember that the david pakman show is
primarily funded by viewers and
listeners like you through the
membership program on our website uh
through the end of the week if you get a
new full price yearly membership for 60
bucks we'll send you a free t-shirt of
your choice six or seven different
designs many sizes and colors available
sign up at joinpacman.com free t-shirt
with a new
full price
yearly membership just email info at
davidpakman.com
after signing up
um we have a really really interesting
conversation to play from meet the press
that gets directly at this inconsistency
when it comes to
the senators who won in november of 2020
saying
that donald trump actually won in the
election results can't be trusted i'm
not gonna put it up on the screen again
because you i i get uh i get flak every
time i do it
i sent a tweet out shortly after the
election saying something like you know
all of these republicans saying that
biden stole it
they were elected on the same ballots
where it would say senator or congress
and then on the same ballot president so
how could it be
that the trump biden results are
illegitimate but their results are
legitimate wouldn't they have to
question the legitimacy of their own
election of course they're never really
ever uh held accountable for that
inconsistency
until now
senator roger marshall a republican from
kansas was on uh meet the press and
interviewed by chuck todd on sunday
and in this conversation
chuck todd asks him do you believe you
were elected fair and square and he says
yeah yeah i was
and then he's asked about whether joe
biden was really elected fair and square
and he says well i i do have concerns
about election integrity and he drops in
a bunch of other coded language that
these people are now regularly using to
avoid dealing with the truth truth and
addressing these issues substantively so
we're gonna look at all of it this is
close to three minutes it's a longer
clip than we normally play but it's
worth seeing the full kind of arc of the
conversation so let's watch it and then
we're gonna have a conversation about it
uh you brought up bob dole at the
beginning we're gonna have our own sort
of tribute to him later in the show
but i'm curious of this senator
um bob dole conceded the election in
1996.
the last president has not
what could the former president learn
from bob dole
well listen i i think that this is an
issue of election integrity um and i
think that's what's really important to
americans across the nation we we value
the the ballot and the ballot booth we
want election integrity uh there's a lot
of controversy out there and i'm focused
right now on making the making it easier
to vote and and harder to cheat i think
that's the focus right now well i want
to actually bob dole one of the last
interviews he gave was in july to usa
today he actually was asked about the
former president he said this he lost
the election and i regret that he did
but they did he had rudy giuliani
running all over the country claiming
fraud he never had one bit of fraud and
all those lawsuits he filed in
statements he made i'm a trumper i'm
sort of trumped out though
um
do you know you voted you you stood with
those that didn't want to certify the
election do you regret that now
considering all the crazy cockamamie
things that mark meadows and others were
doing
look i'm always going to stand up for
election integrity i i want to make sure
that every state obeys their own laws
and obeys their own constitution
especially in a time of crisis so that's
what's at risk for me right now is
maintaining the integrity of that
election and i want to do everything i
can going forward to make sure make sure
that those elections have even more
safety valves in it that there's higher
levels of integrity americans value the
sanctity of that that ballot booth do
you believe you were uh elected fair and
square in 2020
you know absolutely i do i think kansas
has some of the tightest election laws
in the land uh we went back and looked
looked at that to make sure that it was
a safe and fair election so proud of our
secretary of state so proud of our
county clerks and those people that
volunteer checking the ids to make sure
that every person got one vote uh we're
just really proud of how kansas could do
it other states could look and see how
kansas does it
and do you believe that joe biden was
elected fair and square
you know joe biden was sworn into office
i called him mr president since the day
he warning questions i still remain
concerned about election and i still
remain concerned about election
integrity i i think that that we need to
go back and look at what did the states
obey their own laws do they obey their
own constitution so there is a lot of
kind of mushmouth nonsense in there i'm
concerned about election integrity
there's lots of controversy that's one
of those things where yeah
your side created the controversy out of
thin air and then points to the fact
that controversy exists to say well we
should really slow down because if
there's so much controversy maybe we
can't trust those results well what's
the reason for the controversy the other
kind of coded line that he uses there
is
we want to make sure that states obey
their own laws that is a garbage pond
scum argument that they have come up
with and the way that that one works and
i know some of you know it is
you hear this line all the time
states changed their election rules
without going through the legislature
and thus it is
illegal
unconstitutional
fill in the blank
this is not true
there are provisions that allow the
states that changed the make all of the
parameters some of the parameters of the
election there are provisions that allow
that to be done without going through
the legislative process in some states
it was done related to covid in others
it was not done related to covet but it
was still done and legally it is legal
to do that they insist it's not but it
is
the other
kind of linguistic trick that they use
often
is when he was asked is joe bi did joe
biden win fair and square
marshall says joe biden is president and
he was sworn in
and chuck todd rightly points out that's
not an answer to the question i asked
we're not asking do you recognize that
joe biden is the president today saying
no to that is an extra level of wacky
the question is whether joe biden came
to be the president today
through an election that he really won
fair and square and so whenever they say
joe biden was sworn in and he is the
president when they are asked did he win
fair and square
they are avoiding saying he won fair and
square it's just a game that they play
and at the end of the day the game that
they're playing is if i won it's fair if
you won you cheated
even if i actually cheated no if i won
it's fair if you won you cheated it is
only hypocrisy
if you believe that consistency matters
and as we talked about earlier in the
show
they don't care about even appearing to
be hypocrites i i don't know what i was
looking at the other day
but
in the lead-up to trump winning in 2016.
i don't know how many of you remember
this when there were good jobs numbers
under barack obama good unemployment
numbers under barack obama trump
insisted that the numbers from the
bureau of labor statistics and the uh
from the beat from the bureau of labor
statistics and department of labor were
false you couldn't believe the numbers
and
within i think it was like his maybe his
first but certainly by his second or
third press briefing when sean spicer
trump's first press secretary came out
and said we just got great jobs numbers
and it was like trump's been president
three days it couldn't possibly have
anything to do with trump it's for the
previous week before trump was even
inaugurated a reporter said
trump called these numbers fake
before he was president
are they no longer fake and sean spicer
laughed through it but he said
the numbers are now very very real the
president now trusts these numbers
completely they don't even pretend not
to be hypocrites and this goes back to
my commentary from probably eight nine
months ago at this point where
they might
realize that they are lying
they might realize that they are
hypocrites they might realize that they
are holding themselves to a different
standard than they hold the left but
they don't care because they see this as
being in a moral holy war and if you're
at war much like if you're in a literal
war you might say
we might have to do some things we
wouldn't do in normal circumstances
we're going to have to accept that some
of us are going to behave horribly
because we're at war and the end the
means justify the ends it's the same
thing here
that they see
whether it's lies hypocrisy whatever
they see it as a justifiable means to an
end
they believe they are fighting for
in a moral and uh principled way and
when that's the case
how can you talk them
into behaving like normal rational
honest consistent people you can't
and that's what's going on
we told you that uh dr mehmet oz
known for promoting all sorts of quack
cures on his pseudo-medical tv show
is running for senator in pennsylvania
as a republican candidate
this is a very important 2022 race and
in fact control of the senate in the
next session
could hinge
on whether dr mehmet oz wins the
pennsylvania senate race
dr oz is now very quickly coming to i'm
the victim they are canceling me
he says the philadelphia enquirer and
others are trying to quote cancel him
by making the editorial decision to call
him mehmet oz instead of dr oz in their
publication that's that's it and he says
they're trying to cancel me there's
actually really interesting both grammar
and journalism behind this there are
many media outlets in fact that have
decided that when they talk about dr oz
they will say mehmet oz a doctor from
pennsylvania or you know whatever state
they identify as being from not dr oz
why well the philadelphia inquirer has a
style guide the style guide has existed
for a while their style guide says do
not use doctor
on the first reference for anyone with
the title
whether they are a medical doctor or
have a doctorate in a non-medical field
to avoid complaints of unequal treatment
from individuals who worked hard to
achieve doctorants doctorates in
non-medical fields so
the philly inquirer rule is we just
don't refer to people generally speaking
as doctor regardless of whether they are
medical doctor or not because if we did
then all of a sudden you've got anybody
with a phd in anything you have to say
doctor every single time might be
confusing etc they have two exceptions
exception number one is in obituaries if
someone has died
you say doctor whatever and if you're
talking about reverend
uh dr martin luther king jr that's their
exception
other papers have rules for not using
doctor
in popular culture but yes in science
as an example so if you're writing an
article about medicine and you quote a
doctor you say doctor whatever if it's
popular culture you don't now that's
what's at the core of this
dr oz
is his pop culture name
he is mehmet oz
television host who plays
a doctor he he is a medical doctor but
in his role in culture he has a show in
which he is
a doctor that gives advice about
different things so anyway dr oz is
furious he says that this is a
cancellation let's watch him explain it
no they're not they're putting their
thumb on the scale here's the thing
they're such an enthusiastic response to
the campaign i'm here in pittsburgh
talking to people and it makes me
optimistic because they've got great
ideas meanwhile the inquirer hates hates
that i'm empowering you hates that i'm
taking on some of the established folks
that the entrepreneurial solutions that
i'm offering might make sense and they
don't like that i say what i see so they
want to silence me and i tell you it is
shocking that it would make them that
uncomfortable this early in my campaign
but i think it's reflective of the
movement we represent well they're
trying to cancel you i saw your twitter
that's what you said
and the twitter response that i posted
back got a huge response because people
see it i mean you can't look away why
would the inquirer get involved in this
process why would they not want to call
me dr oz everyone knows i'm dr oz but
they don't think it's the right thing to
do they think it gives me an unfair
advantage so that is that really is very
interesting and you know rand paul is a
doctor senator rand paul is an
ophthalmologist uh he was not referred
to as dr rand paul during his campaign
uh it was rand paul
ophthalmologist from kentucky okay
totally reasonable the difference here
is that for
mehmet oz
dr oz is actually his his cultural
identity it's more than his profession
and in fact
when we say dr oz is running we're not
saying the guy we know as a surgeon dr
oz is running we're saying dr oz the
figure from the dr oz show
but the truth is it's mehmet oz who's a
doctor it's his personality it's his
celebrity built around the character dr
oz that is why we know who the guy is
who is mehmet oz a lot of people
wouldn't even know if you said to people
who is mehmet ozzy i don't know who's dr
oz oh yeah the guy from tv that makes
sense so i do believe
that dr oz has an argument to say i'm
known as dr oz as a brand
not as a professional these people don't
know me as a doctor in terms of my
relationship with them they know me as
the brand dr oz from tv he's probably
right that it is better for him to be
written up as dr oz instead of mehmet oz
but also publications have to make
decisions and typically
particularly when it's not about
medicine they name candidates by their
names mehmet oz a doctor from
pennsylvania not dr oz so completely
agree with the decision
he's not being canceled their editorial
policy is in writing and they're
following it if you disagree with me let
me know we'll also have more on this on
our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
find me on instagram
david.pacman as well
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today michael cohen michael is the
former personal attorney to donald trump
also author of the book disloyal a
memoir and host of the maya culpa
podcast it's really great having you on
i appreciate it oh it's good to see you
david how you doing pal i'm doing well
um last time you and i spoke was on your
program and you said two things that
were interesting i'm wondering if you
still feel the same way uh one was you
do believe that ultimately donald trump
is going to be indicted and two that you
do not think that he is going to run for
president in in 2024 that was a few
months ago do you still feel the same
way
yeah i actually do uh nothing has
changed other than the greater american
grift by donald and cohorts
whereby you know their whole intent is
to make you believe that they're going
to run in 2024. because the second that
they tell you that we're not that's when
the spigot of funds from all of these
republican fools that are standing
behind donald will end up shutting off
um what is the that is that the only
reason to keep the grift going right now
that he may run just to keep fundraising
is that all there is to it
yeah otherwise what else is there for
him he knows he's not running because he
can't afford to lose a second time you
see again the big lie is only promoted
by the notion that the election was
stolen from him if in fact the election
was not stolen from him what happens to
the big lie you can't say in 2024 oh
they stole it from me again it's almost
like holy sh right quite frankly they
did it to us again they did it again and
it just doesn't work anymore the first
time you know like the old expression
first time shame on you second time
shame on me well this one would be a
shame on me moment and donald can't
afford that and statistically he already
knows that he can't win the general
election
on the criminal stuff
who's going to charge him and for what
crimes i think is the most common
question i get when the topic of that
comes up what are the answers to those
questions well it makes it makes sense
david that that's the number one
question that comes to you it happens to
be the number one question that
everybody keeps asking me
unfortunately you know i don't discuss
the summon substance of the district
attorney
or the attorney general's case here in
new york um the things that we do know
is that it's predicated upon valuation
of assets
using those valuations for loans and
other things but there's also then the
second half which is the devaluation
of the identical assets for tax purpose
okay so
without getting into detail about your
involvement it's not the obstruction
stuff that people are talking about
during the presidency it's these are
we're talking about financial stuff here
from the business
well that's what we're talking about
with the district attorney the district
attorney in the state of new york would
have absolutely no jurisdiction over the
january sixth insurrection that's
clearly federal
um when you uh i mean just for context
for people who may or may not know i
mean you had a long history of
supporting democratic candidates for a
very long time right i mean how do you
define your personal politics
david i've been a democrat my entire
life in 1987
i worked for congressman joe moakley of
massachusetts uh while i was attending
american university uh i have
been a democrat my entire life until
ultimately i was required to switch
parties uh during the uh campaign
because actions i should say post the
campaign uh because uh i was the first
democrat who held the position as vice
chair of the rnc finance committee and
they just couldn't accept that i mean it
makes perfect sense yeah and so they
said we can't have a democrat running
the finance committee for those yeah
well yeah fortunately for them it was
being run by steve wynn who just did a
remarkable job in terms of fundraising
it was steve wynn myself it was elliott
broidy and lou dejoy right it was really
the four of us and obviously they
couldn't have a democrat on that
that team
so in the last 24 to 48 hours we heard
about these text messages that were
allegedly sent to the former chief of
staff mark meadows on the day of the
january sixth insurrection it included
laura ingraham the fox news host texting
meadows and saying this is looking
really bad hey david david i'm sorry do
we pronounce it is it ingram or is it
ingraham i mean i've heard people say
both personally i think can't stand her
either way i don't care i don't care how
you pronounce the last thing i'm just
trying to to you know get an expert
meeting yourself i'm trying to get an
expert analysis on this i've said
ingraham and people say that that's not
correct
because i've heard it i hear it as
ingraham i hear this ingram like i said
i can't stand her either way it doesn't
make a difference to me but i just want
to at least pronounce the yes name right
so she was texting mark meadows on the
sixth sean hannity was texting don jr
instead of texting his dad was texting
mark meadows
for me the most interesting thing about
those text messages
is that the story that they told after
about it might have been antifa
and
it was really no big deal they obviously
knew on january 6 that it was trump
supporters that were there what else do
you make of the fact that so many people
from fox were texting mark meadows as
this was going on
are you shocked is there anything about
that question that shocks you that fox
and newsmax and oann wouldn't be [ __ ]
lying about this
seriously i mean for god's sakes the
whole thing again is a it was an
insurrection and
what we know now as a direct result is
that
177
187 minutes transpired before dear old
donald came out and said hey i want
everybody to disperse go home and that's
because he had his fun over those three
hours watching these these
mega fools running around in
paramilitary gear right beating up on
police officers out there with these
massive maga flags and trump 2020 and
you know god knows what other stupid
swanky swag
that they thought that they were wearing
running around all right for the benefit
of who their fuhrer donald and for some
unknown reason the guy sat there in the
in the white house in our house
watching the [ __ ] on television and
thinking that it was okay that this is
good that he's going to somehow stop the
electoral decision process from
declaring joe biden as the
as the president of the united states
and that somehow he would be reinserted
as president of the united states for
another four years despite the fact that
he lost by close to
nine million votes
and that the electoral count was at
absolute air speeding
the um the stories from that day are
that all sorts of people were urging him
do this do this do that
and that he was ignoring it at least for
a while
when you were working for him was that a
common occurrence where you would go and
say this is not good for you we need to
do abc and that he would just ignore it
on the idea that he knows more than you
do
right so donald knows more than
everybody let's just look back because
everything with the reason why i'm so
successful in predicting donald trump's
stupidity is because first and foremost
i graduated um valedictorian from trump
university all right that's first and
foremost
second it's because nothing with him is
original it's all like a regurgitation
of past [ __ ] coming out so yes donald
trump does not listen to anyone donald
trump knows more than everyone let's
look at some of the things that he said
he knows more about epidemiology though
he didn't use the word because he
doesn't know the word nor can he spell
it but he knows more about science than
the scientists again referring at that
point in time to epidemiologist
extraordinaire dr anthony fauci and the
covid virus he knew more about it what
else does dear old douchebag donald know
more about he knows more about military
and strategy than our
generals i mean if you're not scratching
your head at this point while watching
the show and saying come on seriously
the [ __ ] outta here already you know
more about seemingly everything
than anybody else and yet you're an
expert in nothing
right why don't we talk about being
since you know so much how trump vodka
do how trump mortgage do right how did
you know trump's stakes do how did
trump's suits do how did trump anything
do the
brand is worthless because truth be told
he showed himself
for what he really is and i say it all
the time he's a racist sexist
misogynistic xenophobic homophobic
islamophobic anti-semitic germaphobe
that's who he is and so how you could
expect that this is going to be the guy
that knows more about everybody and
everything it's just not true in fact
what do we know he's ignorant and he's
arrogant
hey on the ante just to pick one one of
those 10 things on the anti-semitism
stuff
you know um you were his personal lawyer
for a while his daughter converted to
judaism his son-in-law is jewish his
grandkids from from them are are jewish
there's sometimes these there there are
people i've met
who harbor anti-semitic beliefs but they
sort of want to be in league with jews
for lightly anti-semitic reasons like
they think they're clever like the
saudis for example now are very
interested in doing business with
certain
hedge funds that are run by jewish
individuals can you talk a little bit
about the seeming inconsistence between
the number of jewish folks in his family
and what you believe to be his
anti-semitism
okay first of all in order to sort of
care
about
the jewish people in order to care about
forget about his workers right myself
alan weiselberg alan garton larry glick
and a whole slew of other individuals at
the trump organization in high-ranking
positions right being jewish he doesn't
care
if you're able to accomplish what he
needs he wouldn't care what race religio
well actually he wouldn't care what
religion that you are but yes he does
find jews to be clever and so that was
something his father taught him you know
that they're okay if you work for him
now as far as ivanka you know be um
obviously becoming jewish um converting
um you know
now being uh what do you call it you you
know orthodox but modern orthodox uh
having the three you know jewish
grandchildren
why donald trump doesn't care because in
order to care about somebody else's
religion you have to care about your own
and donald trump does not care about his
own religion because he had no religious
upbringing nor does it you know when he
turns around and he's holding the bible
it's another lie and he says i know more
about you know corinthian you know
corinthian 2 and so i mean
it
the guy
never went to church the guy went to
church for maybe his um confirmation and
then stopped but he doesn't have
religious convictions therefore when
people say to me oh but his grandkids
are jewish so clearly he can't be
anti-semitic
it's the stupidest comment that somebody
can make you can't care about you know
about christianity if you don't care
about your own religion you can't care
about islam
if you don't care about your own
religion that's just a fact he has no
religious conviction at all could care
less not just about his grandkids or his
daughter's religion but he doesn't care
about his daughter or his grandkids
either
um wow
okay by the way he didn't give a [ __ ] he
didn't give a [ __ ] about his own
children throughout his entire life
let's just let me just back it up with
facts something that i continuously do
despite the fact some people want to
hear it and those that do already
despise the [ __ ] guy anyway and those
that don't
again would allow him to shoot someone
on fifth avenue and get away with it
he walked out on his three children
that's okay many people get divorced i
get it he walked out on them but he
basically had little to nothing to do
with them he was an absentee father all
along don then for you know went to the
hill after hill school then ivanka went
away to boarding school came back uh
then eric as soon as that he was old
enough went off to boarding school as
well he you know then he has tiffany
from marla sends her off to california
barely sees her maybe once a year on her
birthday they speak all of a sudden now
it's daddy daddy daddy oh i loved him he
was such a great father that's not the
she used to tell all of her friends
right and now you have baron when was
the last time you saw baron when was the
last time like in if if i was president
of the united states i'd be throwing a
baseball with my kid right because
that's my son's sport right or we'd be
tossing around a football
i would probably even build a tennis
court in the backyard so my son and i
could hit or my daughter and so when you
see my children you never see baron
anywhere he barely has anything to do
with that child either right i mean now
all of a sudden he's going to worry
about his grandkids donald trump doesn't
care about anyone or anything other than
himself period drop the mic uh michael
last thing i want to talk about because
this has been the source of such
controversy
you were a character in the infamous
steel dossier
and specifically in the dossier the
allegation was you went to prague
you met
with either or both russian officials or
those who hacked the dnc and you were
involved there now you've said it's it's
not even a distortion it's just not true
you you've never been to prague right
i've never been to prague i've never
been to anywhere in the czech republic i
don't even believe you know um because
my geography's not great but you know
they claimed that i came in to prague
through germany i've never been to
germany in fact david i've never even
been to russia
and so do you know why that ended up in
the dossier aside from anything else
being true or false do you even know the
origin of that
yeah so the steele dossier as it relates
to me and everybody says well there are
things in the steel dossier that are
accurate or potentially accurate thereby
therefore we can't discount it
completely and i say that's fair that's
fair for you to say
but let me only bring up the 11
allegations raised about me more like
anybody else none of them are accurate
it's [ __ ] christopher steele is a
joke as an mi6 agent who supposedly had
contacts and you know had information
and knowledge um that was relevant to
this christopher steele's a joke the mi6
should be embarrassed of this document
they should be embarrassed that he ever
worked for them it's just absolutely
untrue i have said it since day number
one it has been proven by the fbi that i
was never there right you may even
recall that i somewhere along the line
somebody put out oh it was another
michael cohen that was there and so but
yet they could never produce that
michael cohen's passport i just wasn't
there in fact where was i i was in los
angeles california with my family with
my son who was looking to play baseball
as a picture for usc trojans and we met
with the entire coaching staff he was
being looked at and so you know i know
for a fact that you can't be in two
places at once and i don't have a twin
brother so you know i don't even know
where this came from and yet
it was just used and promoted on and on
and on because this of course would have
been a big deal now some of the things
that i testified before the house
oversight committee as well as to the
select committees of intelligence by
both the house the senate and other
committees and other law enforcement
agencies
was that
i was never in prague however however
the dissemination of the podesta emails
i testified that came from roger stone
in a phone call why that was never
follow through i don't know the answer
it's so
infuriating when i see now that now that
you know democrats have the house right
um
meaning the white house
put the attorney general merrick garland
onto it
roger stone contacted donald i was there
he put it on the speaker box and he said
nothing shy of in a couple did i just
got off the phone with um what what's
his name uh
uh from wake from uh with wikileaks
julian assange with julian assange and
in a couple of days there's going to be
a massive dump of emails that's going to
destroy the clinton campaign and donald
was like okay that's great that's great
right then after when he hung up on
roger you said to me you believe it i
said listen roger's a [ __ ] artist
right it's why of course you call them
the dirty trickster but listen with
roger you never know and lo and behold
was it two three days later massive dump
of podesta's emails did it hurt
hillary's campaign it sure did did it
destroy it no i don't think it destroyed
it but it was every single thing that
roger stone stated
make sure you listen to michael cohen's
podcast the maya culp podcast the book
is disloyal a memoir michael i really
appreciate your time today thank you so
much for doing it
david really good to see you and stay
stay safe out there
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right as many of you
know i am fascinated by scams and it
just so happens that the former
president and the current republican
party have perpetrated a number of
different scams not only on the american
people generally but on their own
followers and donors we've talked about
fundraising scams before one such scam
was that after the 2020 election donald
trump claimed to be raising money for
fighting the election results for
overturning the election and you could
donate presumably to audits and recounts
and whatever else now that was a scam on
its face obviously because they weren't
going to overturn the election
but there were other layers on which it
was a scam as well for example in the
fine print when trump was raising money
to overturn the election results
depending on the promo you would look at
the fine print and it would say
fifty percent of your donation
sixty percent of your donation can be
used not to fighting to overturn the
election but to pay off trump's campaign
debt
prior to the election the scam was
some pre-check boxes when you would make
what you thought was a one-time donation
to trump
one of the boxes that was automatically
checked unless you uncheck it
is that you're committing to an ongoing
donation even though you meant to make a
single and the second box was that in
some cases the amount would go up
whatever your donation there would be
like a multiplier of some kind added on
in the subsequent donation so that was
another scam that they did
there's a new scam now or at least it
has returned the new scam is that the
nrsc that's the national republic
republican senatorial committee is
running a promo called
dinner with trump now if i say to you
we are running a have dinner with me
promo would you expect me to be at the
dinner
i think so
if i ran a promo called have dinner with
my mom
would you expect my mom to be at the
dinner yes i think so
if a celebrity chef
like our friend tyler florence runs a
have dinner with tyler promo would you
expect him to be there
i would
but the dinner with trump dinner
doesn't have trump
this is a huge thing
they're promoting it as enter to win
dinner with trump
do you want to have dinner with
president trump
enter now for your chance to meet
president trump
but then you pull out the fine print
and it says a winner and a guest will
have a private dinner with
senators
lindsey graham
tim scott
and rick scott that there's no mention
of trump
trump won't be at the dinner
for the winner of the dinner with trump
promo or giveaway
um
judd legume or legum
has been researching this and apparently
this is a common scam that trump and
republicans ran during the 2020 campaign
there were all these promos lunch with
trump in chicago
dinner with trump in cleveland all of
this stuff now is it possible some of
these events happened
and trump had lunch or dinner with
somebody
that won the thing i know he had lunch
or dinner but with some of the people
who actually entered
maybe but there is no evidence that
we're able to find that any of these
events actually took place now i want to
be really clear
i don't care about the people getting
scammed here in the sense that
if you're willing willing to do anything
to help trump and these republicans win
donate
whatever for a meal with trump arguably
you've been scammed merely by the
fact that you're supporting this corrupt
party so like missing the dinner is kind
of the cherry on top of the scam but
shouldn't there be repercussions here
because if you run a lottery and nobody
wins you just collect the money that's
illegal when you do giveaways
raffles etc these things are governed by
a bunch of different law
and it's taken pretty seriously in most
cases when you aren't trump i guess or
the national republican senate committee
or whatever it is that they're called
everything is a scam
the campaign itself
the promises that were made but not kept
the presidency itself the fundraising
now even the giveaways are a scam as
well they should be held accountable no
evidence that they are going to be
uh there is just an incredible
new
chapter
in the trump riot investigation i don't
even know where to start setting this up
there was a riot on january 6th
it was trump supporters hundreds of them
are now
in the legal system as their cases go
through
the process
uh there is an investigative committee
investigating what happened it's a house
of representatives committee and there
have now been revealed per
liz cheney
text messages sent listen to this
from fox news hosts
to donald trump's former chief of staff
mark meadows
the texts are remarkable because they
expose number one
how close the connection was between fox
hosts and trump's inner circle which we
knew but it reinforces that but number
two
the content of the texts that laura
ingram sent to mark meadows that
sean hannity sent to mark meadows that
don jr sent to mark meadows
why is don jr texting meadows instead of
calling trump well trump once claimed
his wife calls him sir that probably
tells you a lot about his relationship
with his own kids the texts confirm
that all of them knew it was trump
supporters and they knew it looked
really really bad and their lies later
they knew were lies let me give you some
examples
laura ingram
texted to mark meadows on january 6th
according to liz cheney quote
trump needs to tell people in the
capital to go home this is hurting all
of us
he is destroying his legacy
if it were antifa or blm rioting on
january 6th laura ingram wouldn't have
been saying that she knows the truth of
what happened however that night on her
program laura ingram leads with
a story about antifa's role
in the trump riots suggests that there
were provocateurs this was not genuine
trumpists genuinely rioting writing they
were provoked and she suggests it was
just three dozen people who participated
although she was corrected by kevin
mccarthy on her show
wow so you're saying she knew she was
lying yes the texts prove it
next example brian kilmeade he's one of
the hosts of that
wacky morning show foxenfront brian
kilmeade wrote to mark meadows quote
please get him on tv destroying
everything you have accomplished and
then
killmead played up every lie about what
happened to diminish and to downplay the
seriousness of it sean hannity a known
friend of trump to the extent trump has
friends
wrote to mark meadows can he make a
statement ask people to leave the
capitol
and then hannity proceeded to downplay
it all for months hosting people who
claimed it was antifa and on and on he
knew it was all a lie he was there
texting on january 6th saying this is
bad
this is really bad
other text messages were sent to mark
meadows by don jr
don jr wrote to mark meadows he's got to
condemn this s
asap
the capital police tweet is not enough
imagine having to go through your dad's
chief of staff because he's too
hard-headed or doesn't care enough about
your opinion to actually listen to you
directly and meadows wrote back i'm
pushing it hard i agree trump then wrote
back to mark meadows and said we need an
oval office address he has to lead now
it's gone too far and gotten out of hand
but now don jr just tells lie after lie
after lie about what he supposedly
believes took place on that day he knows
exactly what happened on that day and
they've been lying all along so there
are two stories here one
all these people did see it for what it
is and they're just lying to trump right
now
um and uh i'm sorry and they're lying on
the air right now and then secondly
look at the people who have direct lines
to trump's chief of staff the
relationship between fox news and that
administration
uh really something to behold so every
day
we are learning about more and more lies
more and more deception
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
um yesterday i played a clip of jim
brewer for you the eggman who has been a
loyal listener for 14 years called in
and said i've never fast-forwarded
anything you've done
until you said the name jim brewer take
a listen to this
dave i listened to your show regularly
for i don't know 14 years a really long
time dude okay i've never fast forwarded
past an interview the most boring
interviews i listen to i've learned so
much about being an old man like aubrey
the gray i'm going to live to be a
thousand i've learned so much no matter
how boring it is
but when you play jim brewer i fast
forward 30 seconds fast forward 30
seconds as soon as you said that guy's
name
shalom yes um not a completely unique
reaction i got a number of emails from
people saying
i couldn't listen to that it was too
cringy and listen i apologized after
playing the clip after all we've got a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpacman.com
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show and remember to get on my
newsletter my mailing list at
davidpakman.com january 1st we'll be
doing a
borderline illegal membership discount
special trying to kick off 22 off
strongly
uh very strongly in fact we're looking
at it sign up for my mailing list at
davidpakman.com uh we'll see you on the
bonus show in just a moment
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman